a warning from london to leicester
this city will remain locked down other
restrictions
like those for travel and only having
social gatherings of up to six people
for example
were will remain in force and measures
introduced on the 4th of july
like reopening the hospitality sector
will also
not yet apply watching the announcement
over 100 miles away
was the city's mayor a man angry and
frustrated
by the political handling of this local
lockdown
i'm angry frustrated very disappointed
but frankly not surprised although our
analysis found
infection rates fell here by 20 in the
first two weeks of july
the city still has the highest rate of
infection for its population size
it's here in east leicester where the
virus has been spreading
in clusters many young people have been
bringing it back
asymptomatically to these
multi-generational
and overcrowded homes it's why an army
of volunteers
have been tasked with handing out
self-testing kits
to every household but it comes with
issues
language is a real barrier here and in
heavily south asian populated areas
a car spreading public health messages
in gujarati hindi and punjabi
is desperately needed
but even that doesn't stop people
breaking the rules this man
complaining about lack of social
distancing on this busy road
and in this diverse city the lockdown
has fueled community tensions
outside the hot spots people are annoyed
basically there's no social distancing
at all you know with all these takeaways
and all this
for everybody in the city there's ten
percent of the area that seems to be
um the spot that's the hot spot why
should all of us have to
uh forego our holidays forego our
freedom we're being treated like social
pariahs by the rest of the country
there's one rule for us another rule for
other people
we're trying to do as we're told and
follow the guidelines
and other people are just going out
willy-nilly and doing whatever they like
in other parts of the country more
testing may have led to an increase in
coronavirus cases
blackburn and pendle both areas on the
rise
but with detailed testing data they can
act much quicker
leicester is not yet out of the woods
indications are that it's far off
they will welcome local powers here but
it's something they've wanted from the
beginning
to stop this extended lockdown into my
rashid sky news in leicester